it's interesting our projects come to us
so ever my business partner I have a
company called innovate productions and
for instance a lot of people we work as
a creative producing and a creative and
development producing team but we also
work as a line producer and a upm team
so for example this project they reached
out to us they need a line producer
someone who come in and really manage
this whole team for what we're trying to
do and then other times people send us
scripts and we develop our own content
and we produce it and develop it and
race to finding and do it ourselves and
then sometimes I mean there's we have
another film going on right now that's
actually filming while we're filming
this that friend of ours was directing
yet another producer on it who didn't
know what he was doing so they fired him
and he's like we take him we you guys
come in with your company and take over
the production for me we're like yeah
absolutely
so we did that and that's another reason
why we're tired but it's yeah so we we
do a little bit we're hired but then we
also do Co productions and we partner up
with people to create our own content
and and and put things out there so we
do everything from video music videos to
commercials to feature films and we have
a music video coming up with Holly
Holmes who beat Ronda Rousey coming up
in February and then we're actually
doing a commercial with Ronda actually
with Ronda before she was already 7th
place before she got beat for an energy
company she has a sponsorship that she's
a contract with so you know all types of
different fun things coming our way and
we developed a Halloween TV special
that's right now in development that
should it's in a really good position to
come out next year and so we're kind of
we're kind of moving forward whether we
create ourselves or people hire us we
just like to keep working well Devin you
said you've been doing this 15 years is
that right yeah I've been acting since I
was a child since I was 10 and then I've
been producing for
it's 12 - yeah first film I produced was
2005 so 10 years okay and so in the
beginning in 2005 did you already have
in roads through the acting where you
could reach out to people or was there a
website or some place where you went to
look for people looking for line
producers or east-west at well it's
interesting because when I started when
I first said I want to produce my own
stuff very shortly after that I realized
that no one is just calling you just to
produce no one's calling to say I'm
gonna produce a film with me because
they are there Colin needed to produce
it because they need funding it's part
of a producer Chavez have help rates
funding for it to fund the executive
producers so I taught myself the line
produce know what involves movie magic
budgeting and just read about it and I
was already good with managing money and
managing people I said no no that's not
that bad and so I'd started at first
thing that line produced was a short
film that was about there's a $50,000
your friend pretty good budget for a
short film and just kind of start from
there and then from there just started
saying that this thing I did was a
future film that was like 200 grand and
it's all he just kind of studies [ __ ]
my way up and so I by by by making that
transition until I'm producing it opened
up other doors for people to actually
start calling and open up doors for
producing and for acting and for line
producing and just it was just to give
us a good move for myself because I I
was doing really well and then I hit
like a brick wall you know when I was
like ah man what my manager say when I
hit a certain age I hit a brick wall and
then after a couple years you're kind of
regain your momentum which she was dead
on but that's kind of what I did in my
spare time and now it's you know I'm
lucky to be able to have those different
skills to help you stay busy all the
time
you